equivalence relations are another kind
of binary relation on a set which play a
crucial role in mathematics and in
computer science in particular and they
can also be explained both in terms of
digraphs and in terms of axioms so let's
begin with a digraph explanation of an
equivalence relation and the kind of
relation that's an equivalence relation
is the relation of there being a walk in
both directions between two vertices so
if there's a walk between vertex u and
vertex V and conversely there's a walk
from vertex V back to vertex u then U
and V are said to be strongly connected
and strongly connected is going to be an
example of an equivalence relation so in
terms of the walk relation including
zero length walks the relation that
we're talking about is u g star v and v
g star u now as a property of relations
this has a name it's called symmetry so
a relation R on a set a is symmetric if
and only if a are B implies B are a and
the first remark is that the strongly
connected relation is symmetric an
equivalence relation is a symmetric
relation that is transitive and
reflexive and again we have immediately
that the walk relation of the the mutual
walk relation the two-way walk relation
or strongly connected relation in a
digraph is an equivalence relation
because clearly if there's two way paths
between U and V and between V and V and
W then there's one between U and W by
going from u to V to W and back likewise
there is a length zero walk from any
element to itself and by definition
strong connectedness is symmetric so the
strong connectedness relation in any
digraph is an equivalence relation and
the theorem is conversely that any
equivalence relation anything that's an
equivalence relation is the strongly
connected relation of some digraph the
proof is trivial it's the strongly
connected relation of itself
okay some examples of equivalence
relations to see why they're so basic is
that the most fundamental one is
equality obviously equality is symmetric
and reflexive and transitive
and so it's an equivalence relation
another one that we've seen is
congruence mod in which you can also
check is symmetric and transitive and
reflexive and finally another relation
would be that two sets are the same size
providing they're finite sets and
another example would be a bunch of
objects having the same color two
objects have the same color is a
relation among objects that have color
that is symmetric and transitive and
reflexive so it's an equivalence
relation let's illustrate some of these
axioms that we have in terms of graphs
it can be helpful to remember them so
reflexive means that when you look at a
digraph it's reflexive when there's a
little self-loop from every vertex to
itself so there's a length one path or
an edge from the vertex to itself in
reflexive graphs
transitive means that whenever you have
two edges connecting a one vertex to
another there's a path of length two
from one place to another then in fact
there's an edge from that place to its
target and of course as we said once
that there's a an edge wherever there's
a path of length two it follows by
induction that there's an edge wherever
there's a path of any length and that's
what transitive means a symmetric means
that whenever you have an edge from one
vertex to another there is no edge back
so in particular if I have an edge from
this vertex to that vertex in blue there
is no edge because it goes back in the
other direction nor is there ever a
self-loop in an asymmetric graph and
finally in a symmetric graph wherever
there's an edge there's an edge that
goes back the other way so that can help
you maybe remember what these properties
mean now
again equivalence relations besides
being represented in terms of the
strongly connected relation of a digraph
can be represented in two other very
natural ways that really explains where
they come
from what their properties are so
whenever you have a total function f on
a set a it defines an equivalence
relation on the set a namely if f is a
total function from domain a to co
domain B then we can define an a
relation we can call equivalence sub F
on the set a by the rule that two
elements are equivalence of F if and
only if they have the same image under F
they have the same thing that is a is
equivalence of F to a prime if and only
if F of a is equal to F of a prime and
again equivalence of F immediately
inherits the properties of equality
which makes it an equivalence relation
and the theorem that we have is that
every relation are on a set a is an
equivalence relation if and only if it
in fact is equal to equivalence of F for
some function f let's illustrate that we
already remembered that congruence mod n
can be understood as equivalent sub F
where the mapping is just map things to
remainders two numbers are congruent mod
and if and only if they have the same
remainder on division by M by n so map a
number a to f of K equal its remainder
and we have found the equivalence of F
representation of congruence which is
another way to verify that congruence is
an equivalence relation finally whenever
you have a partition of a set you can
define an equivalence relation so a
partition of a set it cuts up the set a
into a bunch of blocks which are
non-empty and every element is is a
member of some block and the blocks
don't overlap so in fact every element
is a member of a unique block and that
enables me to define an equivalence
relation on a by the property that two
elements are in the same block in fact
that's the proof of the previous
representation theorem in terms of of a
function that you can map an element to
the block that it's in in order to see
that the block representation and the
equivalence of F representation are the
same the proof in the other direction
that every equivalence relation
can be represented in this way is an
exercise in in axiomatic reasoning an
elementary one that we're going to leave
to a problem and not do in this
presentation so the theorem finally is
that again that a relation R in a set is
an equivalence relation if and only if
it is in fact the being in the same
block relation for some partition and
that is the story and multiple ways of
understanding what equivalence relations
are